even back on with roku marco had been
cultivating himself as a leader
he'd been good at it no matter how bad
things got he always managed to make it
seem like each new hurdle was something
he'd factored in
every solution even once he'd logically
had nothing to do with was somehow his
brilliance
he'd explained once how he managed it
the trick he said
is to have a simple plan that more or
less can't go wrong
so that you always have something and
then you stack your risks on that
have another alternative that won't work
but maybe one time in a hundred
and if it happens you look like a god
and then one that won't work but one
time in 20 that if it lands you look
like the smartest one in the room
and then one that's only one time in
five but you look like you knew you
could do it and if everything else
fails you still got the one that would
always win
if there was a single phrase from marco
that was it always
win hey guys pete here wow what an
episode
it says something when a screaming
firehawk sighting doesn't even rank in
the top moments
this will be a breakdown of the expanse
season 5 episode 4
but first a quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 4 then this
video won't be for you please do hit the
subscribe button on your way out though
and with that out of the way we've got a
ton to discuss so let's get started
as a book reader i have to say welcome
welcome to the new soul system
after the rocks have fallen we've been
waiting for you guys to get here for
years
we made it to the free navy era episode
3
ended with the first rock hitting the
surface and episode 4
opens as each of the different members
of the rossi find out about what
happened
alex kamal and bobby draper are in the
razorback
aka the screaming fire hawk i guess alex
had been holding on to that just in case
he got to change another ship's name
they're in pursuit of admiral soviter
and emily babbage in the bar keith
they're talking about the fact that mars
is dying alex is having a hard time
accepting the reality of it
bobby tells him a story about the loss
of a pet rat named mouse
and so rip mouse and she tells him that
she's went through the same feelings
and that when he comes out the other
side he'll want to be doing something
that matters
we don't learn too much about what
sobatera is up to at this point
alex said that the only thing that's in
his heading is
a squadron from the third fleet that
does look like a supply run
he's meeting up with other martian ships
but bobby doesn't buy it
he sees that the ships adjust their
breaking burn and when they match they
see a flight restriction come up from
the u.n
so in this moment they find out about
that first rock hitting
from the news feed they find out that it
was a blast of 200 to 300 kilotons
and there was also a simultaneous attack
on the martian parliament building
we briefly see them processing what they
just heard
but then it cuts away and this idea of
the blast generating between 200 and 300
kilotons
as i mentioned in my preview video
yesterday there is a lot of debate
online whether these attacks are smaller
or won't have the same impact of what
we've seen in the books this number does
sound lower but we're gonna have to wait
and see because the attack is still
ongoing and the preliminary estimates
could be wrong we just don't know yet
after that we visit our one crew member
who is on earth that's amos
he's made his way to the high security
underground prison
where they keep high-risk prisoners
these prisoners all have body mods like
what we saw clarissa use
in previous seasons amos has come to
visit
miss mao aka melba co aka
peaches they got to know each other on
the way back after the slow zone
incident
and the opening of the ring gates last
season we saw her reach out to him from
the prison
she echoes that conversation when she
says take what they give
give nothing in return she's in bad
shape long story short she got her
implants on the black market
and there's complications to her health
that come along with that we see that
she's hooked up to
a medical machine part of that is
probably related to blocking her use of
the mods like she said but it's also
probably keeping her alive on some level
i'm guessing we'll learn some more about
her condition when we come back to this
interaction
their conversation is slightly different
from what happened in the books
the bottom line here is that he tells
her the world's a messed up place it's a
part of what made them what they are
you know it has something to do with
what they've done he says he was lucky
because someone helped him
speaking of lydia and when she asks if
he's there to help her
he says he guesses he is and it's almost
like he's discovering this
in the moment as she's asking it and
then it does make for a nice interaction
between these two
she believes that she's beyond help but
before they can take it any further
alarms start going off signaling a
lockdown
and then we see a crack in the ceiling
and the lights go out which tells us
that the second rock has
hit i need to move on but i love these
two together so i'll come back to this
at the end of the video
so the second rock hits 40 kilometers
northwest of philadelphia
we find out more about this on luna with
abasarla and delgado
everything that they put together all
their fears are being
realized in real time and delgado says
that they're being blackballed he's
trying to reach out to everyone close to
nancy gal
and no one will take his call luckily
abasarala has her macaroon hookup
on speed dial and she is able to get
through to this chef
on un-one on there we see that nancy gal
won't abandon the planet
and that is admirable and to her credit
she does listen to abba sarala when she
gets the call
christian is able to tell her that it's
the stealth tech that's getting the
asteroids through
and that they need to retast the
satellites because the attack is coming
from marco anaros not mars
but just as it looked like avasarala's
perseverance would save the day
the third rock hits and we see un-1
blown out of the sky
rip nancy gal and this was one of the
most impactful scenes of the episode
because amos and pizzas were underground
it's pretty subtle what happened there
and seeing this from the aerial view
gives us a better perspective of what
actually happens when one of these rocks
hits the earth
just as the reality of how coordinated
this attack is starting to set
in the succession of one rock after the
other hitting the earth
the attack on the martian parliament
building happening almost simultaneously
we see another attack unfold as the
zamiya arrives at tycho station
fred johnson and holden have a plan they
have bull and a team inside the cargo
container that monica stewart was
supposed to be in
they're planning to board the ship and
find out who was behind the abduction
so they can find out who's been giving
away information to the radical opa
things get suspicious really quick the
zamiya starts to slow down
and sakai sort of slips to the back and
just as holden figures out that it's an
attack
things start to pop off bull and his
crew are able to make it out of the
container in time before that's blown
away
but it turned out that sakai was the
mole all along
and she shoots fred johnson in the back
and this is a harrowing sequence
they launched a two-prong attack they
had insiders working on the station
do something in the reactor room that
drew a lot of the attention of the
security forces
after we see fred get hit they fire this
breaching pod
that attaches itself to fred's quarters
when it opens up we see that it has
a spider-looking drone robot inside
and it's there to pick up the
protomolecule sample which he has hidden
in a vault under his bed
monica was inside his quarters so she's
there to witness what happens
the two security guards there with her
are taken out but she's not killed
because they want to take her prisoner
as the robot's cutting out the sample
holden arrives
and monica saves his life twice in a
matter of moments
first he knocks out sakai from behind
and while they fall to the floor
struggling for the gun
holden tries to stop the robot he slows
it down briefly
but then it kind of bit slaps him out of
the way it makes it back to its pod
and sakai sends it off even though she's
not able to make it off tycho
monica is able to secure the cabin and
save holden the second time by pulling
him back
and then sakai takes the moment to rub
it into their faces
that the proto-molecule is gone after
that in a kind of shocking twist
we see that fred johnson does die from
his
injuries this was completely unexpected
he doesn't die till later in the book
series and it's really sad to see him go
rip fred johnson the butcher of anderson
station
he won't get to live to see his dream of
an independent belt
back on luna we see abba sarala
frantically trying to reach arjun
remember he stayed on earth she tried to
reach him at the end of the last episode
and at least right now she doesn't know
where he's at or if he survived
delgado apologizes for not doing more
and we get this great little interaction
between them
as they're realizing that no one has
figured out the line of succession yet
and christian says the fight is not over
and we see a lot of useful information
on the feed behind him they go to a
lounge where other important people are
gathered
she says misery loves company and he
adds so does hope
saying that he knows it's a little trite
and they watch as the watchtower
satellite
detects another rock that looks like
it's heading to the west coast of north
america
and it's able to take that out so it
looks like for now that their efforts
have paid off
and perhaps the third rock will be the
final one to hit the surface
after that we catch up with naomi on the
chat's mocha
when she demands to know where they're
going phillip shows her
marco's ship the pella they dock with
that and when they come through the
airlock
it certainly has a martian look to it
and he says it's one ship of many
that he has and so just from what we see
on screen it looks like they have a
pretty high-tech free navy
she has her reunion with marco and it's
intense
and when she implies that he had philip
kidnap her he sort of slights him in
saying that
it was his idea and he's surprised
because he thought he was a man but in
some ways he's still a little boy who
needs his mother
and all of the actors here do a great
job with the looks on their faces
we see as philip looks hurt by what he
heard and we see
how that affects naomi they can't linger
on that long because marco wants to show
naomi what they've accomplished he wants
to be able to celebrate this as a family
he shows her the feeds of the rocks
dropping
and she responds by saying that he put
blood on their son's hands
just like he did to her philip quickly
interrupts to say that he wasn't forced
to do anything that he was proud to do
his part
and marco makes that clear by saying
that he was the one who got the stealth
tech from mars
dominique tipper does a fantastic job
becoming a mother
who just has heard the worst possible
thing about her son
and then carrall tells marco that the
inners were able to shoot down three
asteroids and that three missed the mark
then we see this subtle but
impressive turn from marco and this ties
back to the excerpt that i opened the
video with
we see him absorb that information which
to be honest
isn't that good we see a smile stretch
across his face as he turns and he makes
a declaration of victory he says one hit
would have been a triumph two proved our
tactical brilliance
but after tree the inners will never
perceive
us as weak again and we see his crew
look
ecstatic and see that they are true
believers and this appeal may spread to
a wider group of people
he has philip take naomi away with a
brief pause to tell her welcome home
and we see her breakdown in her new
quarters as she knows her son is
complicit
in the mass murder of untold people
marco makes his address taking
responsibility for what happened
and laying out the terms of what the
free navy
want he says the attacks are in
retribution for generations of
atrocities
from the inner planets against belters
he says that martians and earthers
have the right to exist but basically
their control ends where their
atmospheres do
everything beyond those planets will be
policed by the free navy
the belt the ring gates and the ring
worlds
and he levies the threat he says that
they have the last remaining
protomolecule sample
and if earth or mars try to do anything
to retaliate for what happened
they won't hesitate to use it on either
planet
it's a stunning turn of events and it's
a real shift in the power structure of
soul system
he calls out for belters to rejoice and
enjoy the victory
and as his address comes to an end so
does the episode
and i did think it was a really strong
episode even knowing mostly what was
going to happen
i still found it to be put together well
it was exciting to watch
fred's death was a complete surprise and
it was shocking in the moment
and it keeps us book readers on our toes
because we're not sure what
else they'll change so that's something
to keep things interesting
the size of the rocks and the damage
that will be done is
up for debate like i said that number is
lower than what i was expecting to see
but it is possible that that's wrong and
things will start to look
worse as they learn more about what
happened marco got his introduction he
got his place in the spotlight and we
saw how
coordinated this attack actually was he
hit earth mars
and the belt all at the same time and he
was mostly successful
it appears that he was trying to destroy
tycho's station
so he wasn't able to pull that off but
he did get the proto-molecule sample
and fred johnson is dead in the books
that's a big failure because they try to
kill fred and it doesn't happen
i thought the acting in this episode was
really superb across the board there
were so many standout scenes and
everybody pulled their weight
i already mentioned it but naomi phillip
and marco all did an incredible job i
was actually surprised how powerful the
clarissa and amos scene was
they both did a really good job there
avasarala
delgado nancy gal really no weak spots
there i really enjoyed zakai's
performance
and with fred dying i think there's a
distinct possibility that we'll see
bull's role increase i have to say that
even though monica saved holden twice i
was a hundred percent with him to go
after the proto molecule
i saw some comments where people were
saying that he completely forgot about
what was going on with monica and was
distracted by the proto-molecule
but i'm here to say i would be too i
think his priorities were exactly right
there
regardless it did get away we didn't see
any drummer in this episode and i'm
curious as to where her story will go
of course her and fred left things on
bad terms but we have to imagine that
she had respect for the man and feeling
so now marco has killed fred johnson and
ashford and i can't wait to see how she
reacts to that
earth may be safe for more attacks now
it certainly looked that way at the end
of the episode
we've had three rocks hit the first hit
near the city of dakar
the second in north america not far from
philadelphia
and the third in south asia it's a
little suspicious that nancy gal
happened to be so near where that third
rock hit
but i'm not sure if there's something
else going on there we opened with alex
and bobby and we still don't know what's
going on with the bar keith i think i'll
do another video in a few days where
i'll look at where everybody
ended and what that sets up for the next
episode it'll be similar to the preview
video i did yesterday
because a lot of stuff is still up in
the air i am very much looking forward
to see what happens with amos and
peaches
i think it's a little bit of a
surprising matchup but i love seeing
these two together in the books
and they're in a pretty serious
situation at this point
in the episode it said that her
penitentiary was in the chesapeake
conservancy zone
and based on what we saw we can expect
that it's somewhat close to that second
impact site so he went underground and
when he goes back up things are not
going to be the same
the way they introduced the attacks in
the books was through his
perspective and he did the same thing
the attack with the first rock was
playing on the news feed as he was
sitting in the waiting room
and he was more concerned with the chair
he was sitting on
whether he could break it away if he
could use it as a weapon
rather than what was going on on the
news and there was
somewhat of a lack of reaction through
all the characters
in this episode i think it's kind of one
of those events where
you take the information in but it
doesn't really sink in it's almost like
your mind can't process it your survival
instinct kicks in
but it's not till later until you really
understand the scope of what happened
and we'll have to wait and see i think
it's safe to say that things will not be
the same
on earth ever again but we won't know
how bad the situation is until we learn
more and i think that's a good place to
leave it let me know in the comments
what you thought
if you're a show only person did you
expect this to happen
if you're a book reader how shocked were
you at fred's death
make sure if you're gonna talk about
stuff that happened in the books you
mark any spoilers
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already i'll have another video
coming in the next couple of days
and plenty more throughout the season
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon